bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy hablaremos de gamal abdel
nasser considerado el padre del egipto
moderno para algunos un dictador para
otros el último faraón se cumplen 50
años de su muerte el 28 de septiembre de
1970 luego de 16 años en el poder nacer
murió siendo un presidente a una
temprana edad y egipto lo lloró porque
de acuerdo con la biografía que escribió
la periodista ann alexander fue el
hombre capaz de enfrentarse al reino
unido- la potencia colonialista que
desde 1882 y hasta 1956 se benefició de
las plantaciones de algodón a lo largo
del río nilo así como de su indiscutible
posición geográfica la bisagra entre
oriente y occidente el dueño de la
península del sinaí por la cual el canal
del suez conecta el mar mediterráneo con
el mar rojo nacer fue un consagrado
revolucionario desde que era joven
fíjense como desde el año 1936 con el
tratado anglo egipcio por el cual egipto
lograba la independent
de los británicos nasser se sintió
profundamente decepcionado de los
líderes de su país en aquellos días
líderes manifestaciones en el colegio al
nahda gritando a todo pulmón por una
independencia total con muchas personas
siguiéndome pero nuestros gritos
murieron en ecos desvanecidos
arrastrados por los vientos según la
biografía de anna alexander para miles
de egipcios el tratado de independencia
en 1936 fue una traición disfrazado de
sistema de semi colonia de manera que
nacer encontró inspiración en uno de los
grandes novelistas egipcios llamado
tofik al hacking con su novela el
retorno del espíritu en la cual se
señalaba que las esperanzas del pueblo
egipcio sólo podrían materializarse en
la figura de un líder carismático
conocido como sad sahagún en un paraje
del libro un arqueólogo francés persuade
a su par británico
no desprecies a esta gente por
miserables que sean hoy les falta una
sola cosa les falta ese hombre en el que
estarán representados todos sus
sentimientos y deseos y que será para
ello símbolo de su objetivo cuando eso
suceda no se sorprenda que este pueblo
produzca otro milagro además de las
pirámides ese hombre vino a hacer gamal
abdel nasser luego de una meteórica
carrera militar
nasser fundó junto con otros colegas la
organización de los oficiales libres con
la cual derrocaron del poder al rey
faruk primero en 1952 dos años después
con la expulsión del general nadie más
él asumió el control de la presidencia
enfrentándose a grandes retos por
delante
uno de ellos recuperar el canal del suez
desde 1936 su decepción con los viejos
nacionalistas egipcios le carcomía puede
que egipto hubiese recuperado el control
de su diplomacia internacional con el
simbólico ingreso a la liga de naciones
pero ocurrió a costa de que los
británicos mantuvieran 10
tropas en el canal del suez o nacer era
por entonces un líder de talla mundial
que en plena guerra fría cuando convenía
tomar partido bien fuera por los eeuu o
por la unión soviética había decidido
mantenerse neutral a la par con el
mariscal tito en yugoslavia y con el
primer ministro negro en la india el
movimiento de los no alineados le generó
resquemores occidentales y como
consecuencia perdió financiación
extranjera para una mega presa que
detuviera las inundaciones del caudal
del bajón iluminó en revancha
nasser optó por nacionalizar la compañía
del canal del suez de inmediato
británicos franceses e israelíes
enviaron tropas para contrarrestar a
nasser pero perdieron el pulso por la
presión conjunta de estados unidos y la
unión soviética aquella victoria de
nasser que valió la expulsión de los
ingleses de la zona que por décadas les
había servido para el tráfico de los
buques petroleros lo puso en la esfera
del liderazgo de dos movimientos
internacionales el panarabismo y el
panafricanismo
si dirigimos nuestra atención a un
segundo círculo el círculo del
continente de áfrica puedo decir sin
exagerar que no podemos así lo querramos
hacernos a un lado de la sanguinaria y
mortífera lucha que devora el corazón de
áfrica entre 5 millones de blancos y 200
millones de africanos en consecuencia
nasser optó por el socialismo árabe bien
visto por los soviéticos nacionalizando
empresas de capitales británicos y
franceses y apoyando las independencias
de sus vecinos túnez y argelia durante
más de una década nasser impuso reformas
agrícolas inversión en grandes
industrias como la del acero expansión
de la educación y la construcción del
megaproyecto de su gobierno la presa de
asuán un proyecto financiado en gran
parte por los soviéticos para producir
una gigantesca planta de generación de
energía
pero llegaría el evento que marcaría un
punto de inflexión en la sólida
estructura política en hacer la guerra
de los 6 días
nasser ordenó el envío y la
concentración de tropas egipcias en la
frontera con israel
el para exigir que un cuerpo especial de
la onu se retirara de la zona israel
teniendo un conflicto lanzó un ataque
preventivo así empezó una guerra de seis
días entre la coalición árabe de egipto
siria y jordania contra el estado de
israel pero la derrota árabe fue
contundente y egipto perdió más de la
mitad de la flota de su fuerza aérea y
nasser humillado renunció pero ni su
consejero anuar el sadat ni la gente en
las calles se lo permitieron quisieron
que siguiera a la cabeza del estado pese
a la derrota tres años después en 1970 y
con 52 años de edad un ataque cardíaco
en el miocardio le arrebató la vida
quien lo seguiría sería su consejero
anuar el sadat así concluimos soy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir
estas historias que las encuentran en
france 24 punto com
[Música]